[Music]
Not only that, you're doing a weird
stuff. Fear Allah. Fear Allah. You're
going to watch this video. Yeah. What
kind of a man are you, man? You can
fall. Let me tell you something. I don't
like calling people the you can fall
into that category. You are outright
putting your wife out there on
display. One skill separates the winners
from those who get stuck. It's not
intelligence. It's not hard work, but
rather it is confidence. And if you
don't master it, you will always
struggle. However, Muslim mastery can
help you fix this. Go to the link, guys,
inshallah, and develop yourself to be
the best version of yourself with
confidence that will get you to places
you could have never imagined. Go to the
link
now. Brothers and sisters and dear
friends, what you guys are wearing in
this hat that I'm wearing, it belongs to
Zishan. He gave it to me. He said, "You
forgot your hat at home. You might as
well wear mine." But it's fine. But if
you think about it guys, it's like
different people wearing different hats
to put on a persona online. And that's
what our video is about today, brothers
and sisters. People who are putting
different hats on at the cost of
destroying their own lives. Here is a
video that was sent to me and I'll show
a screenshot that these things are sent
to me before people think I go and hunt
for them. Yes, this was sent to me by an
individual and we want to watch it now
because I found it, you know, I just
skimmed through this stuff, but I just
found it a little bit distasteful and
very disturbing because when you watch
the videos of these couples, it's a
reoccurring pattern now. So much so, I
have seen sisters blurring out their
husbands and showing their self. I mean,
they've got and can you imagine the the
woman has more for his husband than it
should be vice versa. A time to live in.
Let's watch this video and let me know
what you guys think because this is very
disturbing and I'll tell you where these
things go end up going. Let's watch for
ourselves in
[Applause]
[Music]
So, you guys have seen this. As I'm
going to be talking to you guys, I'm
going to be showing you guys different
stuff that she posts and goes through,
etc. I mean, that act uh first number
one, why do you find the need to kiss in
in public? Forget public, bro. This
actually it's recorded. You've put the
camera there and you've you've actually
told her just how fake it is. You've put
the camera there and you've said, "I'm
going to do a and then I'm going to do
this and I'm going to do this and I'm
going to do this." It's fake and you
know it's fake. And going there and
going into a sexual position, that's a
sexual position. And I'm here talking
about you and your wife's sexual
position. Well, that's a sexual
position. Her jumping on you like that
is a sexual position. And not only that,
you're getting your hands underneath her
thighs that she had to cut out. Where
was the position going to? It went from
this to something else, bro. what he's
going to do. I don't want to get into
details. Okay. What I'm seeing is this
though. It's disgusting. Even though
you're a married couple is disgusting.
If your father was watching this sister,
do you would you show this to your
father? Would you go to your father and
say, "Father, look, look what look is my
husband. Yeah, it's halal. Look, I'm
showing the whole world. Look what
positions he's putting me into." Would
you go to the prophetam and show that to
him? You will not even show that to your
father. You will not show that to your
brother. The point is this now before
people like, "Oh, no, no, haram please.
Let me tell you something here. I don't
care. I don't care. I'm not here for
people's opinions or their
approval. Ysef
Alisam Ysef Alam sees a dream of 11
stars if I'm not mistaken and a sun and
a moon and this dream is given told to
his father and his father interprets it
in a way which he knows. Yes, his father
was a prophet and his father was also a
prophet as well. His father tells him he
doesn't say to him don't tell
strangers. He doesn't say don't tell
strangers. He says don't share this
information with your
brothers. With your own brothers
blood brothers and sisters, we are
seeing this trend and this is coming
from irresponsible behavior. And we
talked about this on the bitter truth
show when we discussed it. This one of
the reason I discussed this
irresponsible social media couples who
was go who are going out there and
putting their lifestyle and pretending.
Let me tell you something. They
orchestrate this. I promise you they
orchestrate this. You know why? Because
I can remember when COVID happened, me
and my wife were doing reminders where
obviously because I need a female to
hold on to and my wife is the only one
that I can touch in a hal way or my you
know in that way it's like touch holding
a hand. I got my wife to be on certain
skits. We didn't share our lifestyle.
We'll talk about stuff that reminders
etc. whatever it is. Yeah. And I could
remember I would have to tell her okay
you're going to do this and you're going
to come and do that and I'm going to do
that. She's like okay. I'm like let's do
okay let's do it again. I know how it
was. My wife was like, "Oh, no." Cuz my
wife is very picky with this stuff. Oh,
no. My, you know, I don't want, you
know, she doesn't even like to talk on
camera. Yeah. So, she was like, "Let's
do that again." I was like, "Oh my gosh,
it was so long." My wife would, I'll be
honest with you, my wife was, "Oh, no."
But, BL, she was very, very, and she she
doesn't want to be on social media. And
I respect that, but it's because I had
no one else to use for that in the sense
where having a person symbolizing the
opposite gender. I know how what goes
into. And it's not that obviously we're
faking the thing. But now imagine you're
doing videos where you're trying to
promote your lifestyle, etc. You can see
on Instagrams. Yeah. Okay. All the stuff
that they're doing, it's
fake. And let me tell you something. You
guys are not happy. And I'm telling you
straight up. What do I mean by that
behind the scenes? This is not the
reality. You know, you guys have
arguments. You know, you've been on the
verge of divorce. You know, you've had a
big bus ups. You know, you've had big
fights. Chaos. But you have to put an
act on for your followers. Let me tell
you something. When you go into this
vicious cycle, it is going to explode
one day or another. And promise me and
not that I want that on you guys and I
ask Allahhana to preserve your marriage,
protect you from divorce. Not that I'm
asking for it, but at this rate when so
many people are watching, let me tell
you something. There are people out
there who are not married. There are
people out there who will come and
compare their life to yours. It is
irresponsible behavior to go out there.
There's jealousy. There's envy, there's
evil eye, there's black magic, there's
so much going on and you are going out
there and blasting your whole life. Let
me tell you something. You know why I
say this? Because me and my wife, we
also travel. We do also go holidays with
the kids or whatever it is. Have you
ever seen me ever, ever, ever show you
where I am, what I'm doing? Do you know
why I don't do it? And it's not that I
want to cook about it. It's nothing to
be proud of. Yeah. Okay. If there's
anyone that's a little bit vocal about
his private life to a little extent,
it's me and even my friends like Zishan
tells me I said bro be careful and I
admire that and I respect him for that
because I know he cares about me. If he
was not my will she like yeah bro yeah
yeah just mentioned your wife and he's
very strict with this and I admire that.
Why? Because I don't have the need for
your approval. I don't need to go and
say, "Hey, an insecure person, a person
who is selfish and only cares about
their self does what?" They want to show
you this fake lifestyle. Yeah. Fake
lifestyle of out there like, "Yeah,
look, we're living a life." Let me tell
you something. Most people do this. They
don't do it for the do for others.
They're putting this fake persona, fake
lifestyle. Are you really telling me
your lifestyle is like that? It's not.
You're lying to the people. You are
lying. Not only that, you're doing a
weird stuff. Fear Allah. Fear Allah. You
you are a man. You're going to watch
this video. Yeah. What kind of a man are
you, man? You can fall Let me tell you
something. I don't like calling people
the youth. You can fall into that
category. You are outright putting your
wife out there on display. Bro, let me
tell you something. A woman's face is
not a Okay. It's not. And you guys
noticed we have a f we show like for
example a a woman's face or if
non-Muslim woman for example, hijab is
not obligated on them. Yes. Okay. But
your wife is so kicked up, bro. I have
to I have to blur her. I have to blur
her. You know why? because I have some
kind of um as her being my sister in
Islam over you, bro. Like, what the f?
She's fully caked up and you're there
showing her body, showing the stuff that
she wears, underwear, whatever it is for
that matter. Do you not have no shame?
Do you not have no shame? The prophetam
pointed to the graves and he said, "Do
you know how many people are in these
graves because of evil eye?" Because of
evil eye. So, your lifestyle is fake. My
dear brother and sister, I'm telling
you, you will destroy your marriage.
Mark my words, give it months or years,
a day will come where they would end up
disappearing on social media. All of a
sudden, I'm telling you, we've seen
couples who've put this persona up and
we found out that either the guy is a
crackhead, beating her up, or vice
versa, she's a absolute maniac crackhead
who's doing the opposite to him. Why?
Because when you have this lifestyle,
you have to fake it. Fake it. fake it.
You have an argument. You have a fight
and you know what I'm talking about.
This couple, whoever they are, okay, I
don't know what their name is on um
Instagram for that matter. Yeah. What do
you need to do? You need to start faking
it. And you know, you've argued, but at
least for the camera, can we just do
this? You know, cuz this is our uh
source of means of income or we like the
likes and shares or whatever it is for
that matter. So, all I'm going to say is
this trend is carrying on and all we're
saying is wah you've got in the comment
section. Look, let me show you guys the
comment section. Message for
non-Muslims. This is not Islam. Okay,
people commented. Yeah, somebody wrote
there as a
Catholic got 19,000 likes. 19,000 likes.
Even can you imagine a non-Muslim, a
kafid is coming and telling you what
you're doing is haram. What you're doing
is haram. So my dear brother and sisters
who are watching this and these fake
fake videos of these irresponsible
individuals, don't fall for it. Stop
looking at them and thinking this is
marriage because you are coming into
marriage with false expectations, false
sense of reality. And when you get into
marriage and you get into a fight,
you're thinking this not supposed to be.
Everyone has ups and downs. Marriages
get chaotic, crazy, upside down. It is
normal. Don't watch these irresponsible
individuals and um use this as a metric
to how successful your marriage should
be. These people are sadly selfish. I'll
be tell you very categorically they
don't care about you and your marriage
and what it's going to do cuz if they
did they wouldn't do this. That's the
reason why I don't share my lifestyle
with you. I can have amazing moments
with my wife on holiday. I can look I
can easily come and put a camera up and
yeah we are going here and traveling and
let me tell you something. It shows that
I'm an irresponsible person. I'm an
insecure person. I need your likes and
views and your opinions whatever that is
where they are going and they do not
care about you. So brothers and sisters
inshallah this trend is continuing
inshallah and we need to raise awareness
to this. May Allah subhana wa ta'ala
allow these individuals to come to their
senses inshallah. And please, please,
individuals like this that make you feel
like crap when you're watching them and
feeling like, you know, I can't find a
partner. Look how amazing their
marriages. Wall it is all nonsense. BS.
Full-blown BS. Fivestar grade A BS.
Don't fall for it. Protect your mind.
You're watching with your eyes. The the
heart doesn't desire what the eyes don't
see. So my dear brothers and sisters in
with the divorce rates skyrocketing one
of the reasons one of the things that
you should do for your own mental health
is keep away from these individuals
inshallah brothers and sisters and one
last thing I'm going to say inshallah
you guys might know of Idris and froggy
I think her name is froggy or froggy
what for that matter they she has even
decided to come off his vlogs yes
because of these reasons. Subhan Allah.
So brothers and sisters that's all I'm
going to say till next time.
May Allah protect and preserve you